did you see the R Kelly thing first of
all I sent this to the group chat
and he goes like this and and Mike my
opener who like thinks about birds a lot
flying probably because he's [__]
it is uh
he goes oh it's fake and it made me mad
because he's just a [__] nicer and
it's not fake and if you know anything
about he's like look doesn't look like
the the lyrics are matching up with his
mouth and I'm but you got to understand
they were filming it in a [__] Arena
so they got the Reverb and the [__]
uh the time delay and all the [__] and
you got to understand you gotta know R
Kelly you got to be smarter than that
and know about what R Kelly would do and
this is right in line with what he would
do
if you haven't heard this I'm going to
play it for you
now
R Kelly is a bad guy obviously he pisses
on 14 year olds nothing worse nothing
worse
okay
but this guy if he wasn't a bad guy and
an actual good guy this would be the
most illest song of all time because
it's Essa basic and he just says what he
wants that's the thing I like about r b
it's the thing I liked about R Kelly's
songs too until I realized he pissed on
12 year olds is that it was so just like
I'm in the closet next to it parka
and you'll be like oh it doesn't mean
anything that's just what it is he's
literally there so this is what he sings
to people in Ethiopia I got it say
elitist
okay first of all things do you haven't
heard this oh wow I haven't get rid of
has not heard this oh oh dude you're
gonna love this bro
have you heard this oh yeah I showed it
to you I got it
[Music]
you have your passport he's in Ethiopia
girl would you like to come back with
Rob to America
[Music]
just to send it home another time set
America again
[Music]
the fact that he calls himself Rob is
really the icing on the cake
like he's like look call me Rob though
[Music]
do you want to come back with I owe
Shakespeare
[Music]
back with r
went back to R wasn't like got a little
bit too familiar with you he was like ah
you know what I don't know I shouldn't
have told him my real name dude dude
did I'm sorry the greatest lyrics of all
time
did you get your shots
like
a badass [__] singing r b but we
still gotta [__] play cool by the
government
you know I mean
you know what I mean you still need your
passport even though I'm gonna do such
dirty things you still need your
passport did you get your shots
and so so full and you gotta see how
many people are at this [__]
do you have your passport did you get
your shots girl would you like to come
back with Rob to America
so unsexy
r b is literally the sexiest
[__] I mean dude
it's the sexiest uh genre of music of
music
I always said r b is the best
uh uh uh the best music and the worst
music
but dude
I'm sorry
sexy sexy as [__] like this this right
here
so sexy you know
it's the 90s this song
foreign
[Music]
Neon Lights
I want to make love to you but I mean um
then there's this
[Music]
that song was this [__] huh
[__] and cream
well you know what no it's what I mean
did you get your shots I mean if 112
just broke up and was like hold up
though did you get your shots you'd be
like what the [__] [__] and cream
dude
I'm sorry but did you get your passport
made my jaw drop and then when he said
[__] did you get your shots
I had to pick it up off the floor like
the mask what is this YouTube this isn't
the [__] duty news